earlier today I spoke with Texas senator
Ted Cruz the stories of heroism and the
people that I have interviewed and
neighbor helping neighbor has been
amazing
I've got to give you a governor a lot of
credit I got to give you a lieutenant
governor a lot of credit the federal
response yet 30,000 National Guard
troops going in are you confident and
this was a question I asked the governor
last night in the short term there are
people that need food water medicine yes
baby formula cots blankets my friend of
my pillow sent 60,000 pillows over you
confident all of these necessities in
the short term would be there and a good
enough plan for those people that will
be years away from getting back in their
homes I am Sean priority number one is
the preservation of life we've seen
incredible heroes from first responders
firefighters police officers EMS
National Guardsmen Coast Guardsmen
rescuing lives the storm is still
ongoing in East Texas in Louisiana
and those rescue operations are underway
the next stage is going to be rebuilding
I've spent this morning at the shelter
at the George R Brown Convention Center
helping serve breakfast helping care for
people there that we had 11,000 people
who had lost their homes who spent the
night there last night and we're seeing
churches and charities and private
citizens throughout the community
stepping up it has been incredible most
incredible part Sean local officials put
out a call just to citizens if you can
help step up in help and we have
hundreds of just ordinary men and women
who had a flat-bottomed boat who had a
bass boat who had said a jetski and went
out and rescued their fellow citizens a
couple of days ago I was at the Harris
County emergency command center there's
an entire wall of post-its of all the
people who called in and said I've got a
boat I can help hundreds upon hundreds
this death toll is horrifying as it is
we lost one brave Houston police officer
it could have been much much higher and
the reason it is and as so many people
risk their lives we're going to have the
resources at the state level at the
local level and the federal level the
president has committed unequivocally to
supporting the people
Texas and Congress in a bipartisan way
I've had senators from both parties
reaching out to me saying we're going to
stand with Texas and Texas will come
through this and we're going to be
stronger Sean all right senator and I've
know my friends at Samaritan pursue
their Samaritan's Purse I know the Red
Cross is there I know churches are all
hands on deck our thoughts and prayers
senator we love the people in your state
we are very sorry for all that's
happened and we wish you the best and
we'll we'll continue to focus on this in
the days weeks and months ahead sir